Ok, they are here, sir; Mr. Creeps and his partner, Mr. Crawls.
At the beginning of this column, someone asked me to make a video about the turning point of the story.
But I always hesitate to do it because I don't want to go through a lot of major story transitions.
I have always adhered to this principle until one day I accidentally saw an interesting study organized by the University of California, San Diego.
The researchers spoiled the end of several famous books in advance to the participants, and then let them read the books.
The other group did not spoil.
After reading, each group indicates how much they like each book.
Based on these studies, it turns out that if you are spoiled before reading, you may prefer these books after reading.
I don’t just think that this study perfectly explains the important points of the story transition.
I also like it because it finds a good excuse for my spoiler.
I will spoil the contents of "Stunning Enchantment" and "First Fear".
"Fatal Magic" will also have a little bit of spoiler.
If you haven't seen it before, think about the research results.
And use this video as a chance to reproduce the experiment.
Well, I started to spoiler.
"We have to follow these footprints to find the monster!"
The general definition of "the reversal of the plot" is: a completely unexpected result of a story.
In The Thunderbolt, Dylan Rhodes is an FBI agent trying to track the "four knights"
However, after the dramatic reversal of the plot, he was always the "fifth knight."
However, I do think that the next movie is very interesting because of a key factor: the turning point of this story has little effect.
Alfred Hitchcock: "Now you and I are sitting here,
Suddenly a bomb exploded! ”
Thaddeus Bradley: "And... FBI let them go. Not once or twice, but always."
Just like them are the participants...
*silence*
Hitchcock: "Once the audience sees this scene, there will be a shock of 5-10 seconds.
*Prelude to Scooby Doo
"Scooby Scooby Doo, where are you?"
"We have some work to do!" * Scooby Doo
Even if the original play is fairly simple, it is quite easy to predict.
"Scooby" actually adheres to the important principle of a good plot transition:
The final outcome is always consistent with the established logic at the beginning of each event.
"They are trying to scare away all the successors on this island."
"Then no one will spend the night here, they will control all the wealth."
We got enough information at the beginning, so when the reversal happens, it makes people very satisfied.
Because you always feel vaguely who is doing this.
Mr. Creeps and Crawls. They must pick the right lawyer to do the job! "
The reversal of "Stunning Enchantment" does not have this element, and it does not conform to the established logic.
From clumsy FBI agents to awkward genius, completely rewrite this character,
It means there is no way to see the reversal of the plot.
This is why it is not very satisfying because it relies too much on people's shock.
"Fatal Magic" is the shocking value brought about by the reversal of "Stunning Enchantment"
And Scooby Doo predicts the perfect balance of logical reversals
In the first twenty minutes of the movie, the film tells us exactly enough information to predict the reversal of this ending.
But Christopher Nolan also missed enough information.
Letting this ending be both shocking and consistent with the established logic.
Hitchcock: "Now, let this scene start from scratch, we tell the audience:
There is a bomb under the table and the bomb will explode in five minutes. "
Outside the painting: "You are looking for secrets, but you will not find them."
Because, of course, you are not really watching. "
The best reversal of the plot is a reversal that can create the biggest surprise without destroying the established logic.
Because at the end of the day, the reversal of "Scattered Thieves" is not so satisfying.
It completely rewrote his character only for a cheap surprise.
The character of the 100% adapted character is not particularly interesting because the character is built through the entire movie.
So, how do you both be both surprised and interesting to do this?
In Tier 1 Fear, this reversal is similar, but there is a key difference.
In this movie, a boy who served as a servant of the altar was accused of murdering the Archbishop.
The lawyer helped him get rid of the crime: "not guilty of mental disorder",
Because the boy showed positive on multiple personality disorder tests
Before the boy moved into a mental hospital, the film ended with a scene:
He revealed that he has been pretending to get a short prison time.
"Sir, there is never 'Allen'"
This looks very shocking, but the ending is actually very close to the logic of the story.
In the whole movie we are not sure which personality he is, and we don't know when he will change his personality.
We always have the feeling that he is not the person he said
But this still makes us extremely shocked.
Because we are always with him, and with him deceive everyone in the play (including ourselves),
At the end of the story, it turned into a rival
We got clues and information, but the shock still exists.
This is where the distinction between a good plot reversal and a bad plot reversal is made.
Hitchcock: "In order to suspend, you have to give the audience enough information,
Allen: "Get it, boy, I thought you finally figured it out."
Hitchcock: "And keep the rest for them to imagine."
Allen: "But let's be honest, I am very glad that you understand.
Because I always wanted to tell you! Haha!
The information should be enough for them to understand its appearance, but not let them anticipate it
(whisper): "I saw the dead."
I think the best way to test the reversal of the plot is to see if it has repeatability.
Because once you know the end of the reversal, (if this reversal is good)
Then when you look back and look for the clues of reversal, there will still be enough fun.
"Are you looking at it?"
I think this is also the result of this study: Why is it spoiled before reading but it makes it more enjoyable, the reason behind it?
The suspense of the ending makes the process even more exciting.
This is probably why many stories have spoiled the end at the beginning of the story.
"As for me! It’s really stupid to kill him!"
Because it is as important as the reversal of the outcome, it is the process of getting the outcome.
So don't be stressed before you look at it, even if you know the ending of the story.
Because - maybe you will like it more?
"So let this puppy come in, others wait inside."
*Dynamic music*
Scooby Doo
Thank you for watching
* Prelude to Scooby Doo*: "Scooby Scooby Doo, where are you?"
Fade out: "We have something to do!"